foreign
15 2021
a massive Arctic Storm is working its
way across the country about to Bear
Down on nearly one-third of the entire
United States
it's 1am
and Mayhem is about to begin
inside the electric grid control room
highly experienced operators are
intensely monitoring power flow demands
on a massive plasma screen that covers
the front wall as well as on countless
smaller screens that line the
surrounding desks
lights are flashing alarms are going off
in every single Direction every sound
having a very specific and Urgent
meaning
phones are ringing everyone is
communicating even the president of the
United States has called in to see how
the situation is unfolding
but there is a huge problem
every single weather event is different
and no one is quite sure what is about
to happen
suddenly
power lines go down
gas pipes begin to freeze grid
conditions get Tighter and Tighter and
Tighter Intel
the power goes out
this happened just a few years ago as
someone who has worked at a grid
operator who has been inside the control
room during one of these events I can
tell you the impact is all too real
in February of 2021 140 million people
were affected
10 million people were without power
and 246 people
roughly the size of this room
lost their lives
did it have to be this way
no
I don't believe so
I'm not here to talk about what should
have happened
rather I'm here to talk about what can
be done to reduce the chance of such a
devastating event happening again
currently in the United States we have
three power grids we have the Eastern
interconnects which is everything east
of the Rocky Mountains the Westerner
connect everything west of the Rocky
Mountains in the Texas interconnect
these three grids operate in isolation
and they don't meaningfully move power
between them in times of need
we need to have a singular nationally
connected power grid
now this will require States working
together
something that I must admit we are not
good at
but the benefits are more than worth it
and I see three huge opportunities
moving forward
a nationally interconnected electric
grid will one promote decarbonization
two increase reliability
and three enable innovation
but in order for us to seize on these
opportunities we need to talk about
something that doesn't often make the
nukes
we need to talk about transmission
lines are specialized power lines
designed to carry large amounts of power
over long distances
they essentially serve as energy
highways and all three electric grids
are dependent on them
but the problem is there are actually
very few interconnection points between
these three grits representing less than
0.13 percent of all transmission
this restricts the operator's ability to
meaningfully move power between them in
times of emergency
we need to invest hundreds of billions
and of dollars in transmission build out
so that we can effectively move energy
around the US
now this might seem like a Monumental
task
but projects of this scale have been
achieved across the history of humanity
thousands of years ago the Romans built
11 aqueducts that brought fresh flowing
water continuously into Rome as far as
57 miles away
a little over a hundred years ago right
here in the U.S the Transcontinental
Railroad was built
this railroad reduced the travel time
from New York to San Francisco from six
months to just 83 hours
imagine what that must have been like
being in that Roman village having that
first taste of fresh flowing water
or being in New York at the turn of the
century walking into a market and
picking up and smelling your first floor
to Orange
these two seemingly Monumental tasks
changed Humanity for the better
and now the next task is ahead of us
a nationally interconnected electric
grid
which brings me to our first opportunity
promoting decarbonization
a nationally interconnected electric
grid will help us move clean Renewable
Power across the U.S
this means we can build windwards
windiest
solar or a sunniest and move that power
around to those who need it
a recent McKinsey report found that in
order for the U.S to achieve its
renewable and emission reduction goals
we would need to invest 450 billion
dollars in transmission between now and
2030.
now this might seem
like a lot a huge investment
but the national renewable energy
laboratory found that investing in
transmission and connecting the electric
grids will yield two dollars and fifty
cents in benefits for every dollar in
cost
seems like a pretty good deal
in the long run this means lower
electricity bills for you and for me
now delaying this investment will only
increase its need
last year in California alone
125 million kilowatt hours of clean
renewable energy which is enough to
power the city of San Francisco for a
week
was wasted because it could not be moved
to those who needed it
but I want you all to think about this
from more than just an investing point
of view I want you to think about it in
terms of our second opportunity
increased reliability
a nationally interconnected electric
grid will increase our reliable delivery
of power
currently in the United States 70
percent of our transmission lines are
over halfway through their useful life
this creates a real vulnerability of the
U.S experiencing increased blackouts
according to the Department of energy
we need to invest hundreds of billions
of dollars so we can further increase
our reliable delivery of power
increase reliability means that
hospitals nursing homes and other
Essential Health Care Services can
continue to operate during times of
emergency
imagine if you or a loved one are in a
hospital dependent on life-saving
technology
and the power goes out
there's only so much fuel in the backup
generators and you have no idea when the
power is about to come back on
reliability in this instance can mean
the difference between life
and death
but once we're able to reliably connect
with each other
we can take advantage of our third
opportunity enabling innovation
a nationally connected electric grid
will be the Catalyst for clean tech
solutions that no one thought possible
10 years ago
by connecting electric customers from
coast to coast we will create a white
space for future entrepreneurs and
incumbent developers alike
similar to the railroad expansion in the
19th century expanding electricity
markets will spark a wave of innovation
and investment like never before
there are already examples of electric
grids around the world becoming more
connected
in Italy 900 million dollars was just
invested connecting the Italian electric
grid to Tunisia
this energy bridge between the European
and African Power Systems will reduce
Italy's dependence on Russian natural
gas and increase their Market potential
the U.S needs to catch up and invest in
its own potential
if countries from different continents
can work together to connect across the
Mediterranean
why can't the U.S work together to
connect across state lines
the technology is already here
engineering already solved
all that is needed is for people to
invest in our power grids long-term
potential
so if you're sitting here wondering what
can I do
the answer is simple
whenever you hear someone talking about
their energy plans whether it's your
local utility or your local
representative
make sure you ask them about
transmission
make sure that they are thinking about
how we move our power
not just how we make it
and if you are in the energy industry
make sure you're asking yourself
what am I doing to prepare
because the world is becoming more
connected every day
and it's up to us to decide whether we
want to be a part of that connection
or risk being alone in the dark
the next big storm is coming
but it can be different this time
because the next big change
a nationally connected electric grid
is coming to
and it will connect us like never before
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]